[Music]
the strength of a family like the
strength of an army lies in its loyalty
to each other
[Music]
when everything goes to hell the people
who stand by you without flinching they
are your family
[Music]
family is not an important thing
it's everything
[Music]
it didn't matter how big your house was
it mattered that there was love in it
[Music]
family means nobody gets left behind or
forgotten
parents are like god you want to know
they're out there and you want them to
think well of you but you really only
call when you need something
[Music]
all happy families are alike
each unhappy family is unhappy in its
own way
[Music]
families are the compass that guides us
they are the inspiration to reach great
heights
and our comfort when we falter
[Music]
family faces are magic mirrors looking
at people who belong to us
we see the past present and future
home isn't where you're from
it's where you find light when all grows
dark
[Music]
in family life love is the oil that
eases friction
the cement that binds the music that
brings harmony
the bond that links your true family is
not one of blood but of respect and joy
in each other's life
[Music]
the family is the test of freedom
because the family is the only thing
that the free man makes for himself and
by himself
[Music]
a happy family is a taste of heaven to
come
you are the bose from which your
children as living arrows are sent forth
[Music]
you don't choose your family they are
god's gift to you as you are to them
[Music]
in every conceivable manner the family
is a link to our past a bridge to our
future
[Music]
having a place to go is a home
having somebody to love is a family
having both is a blessing
[Music]
in time of test family is best
[Music]
show me a family of readers and i will
show you the people who move the world
[Music]
parents were the only ones obligated to
love you
from the rest of the world you had to
earn it
[Music]
some people are worth melting for
[Music]
home is not a place it's people
if you go back there after your people
are gone
then all you can see is what is not
there anymore
family and friends are hidden treasures
seek them and enjoy their riches
[Music]
the only rock i know that stays steady
the only institution i know that works
is the family
[Music]
friends are the family you choose
[Music]
stick to the basics hold on to your
family and friends
they will never go out of fashion
the love of family and the admiration of
friends are much more important than
wealth and privilege
[Music]
you need a rock-solid foundation of
friends and family to keep you where you
need to be
[Music]
the informality of family life is a
blessed condition that allows us to
become our best while looking our worst
there is no doubt that it is around the
family and the home that all the
greatest virtues are created
strengthened and maintained
[Music]
a man should never neglect his family
for business
[Music]
a family is a bunch of people who keep
confusing you with someone you were as a
kid
[Music]
being a family means you are a part of
something wonderful it means you will
love and be loved for the rest of your
life
[Music]
you